yes
[Music]
[Applause]
we're very hello
this evening come on in
i'm actually surprised you all made it
way to go everyone
earlier good job congratulations
welcome to the table my name is karen
really glad you're here
i've got a good evening in store welcome
to everybody here welcome to those that
are online
and i just have a couple announcements
before we get started am i echoing
is it all right
okay all right
first announcement we're having our
welcome to the table class one week from
tonight immediately after the service
that class is for anybody who's
interested in becoming a member here at
the table or if you just want to learn
more outside of what we do on sundays a
little more about our mission vision
things like that
we would love for you to be a part of
that we have these cards that are out on
a little itty bitty table outside the
door over there if you can fill that out
with your name and contact information
and just put
welcome class or you can put wtt for
welcome to the table
drop that in the box and we'll make sure
to get you signed up for that brett is
hosting that and again that is one week
from today sunday after the service
welcome to the table class um if you're
interested in doing that online please
comment and we'll make sure to get you
connected as well
secondly
i can't believe i'm saying this but
easter
is coming
i know
um which means lent is starting uh it's
40 days before easter and that's going
to be march 2nd ash wednesday kicks off
the lint season and we're going to be
joining
pleasant valley united methodist church
they're the church community that meets
right here on sunday mornings
they're going to have a lint sir of ash
wednesday service
march says at the second i think it's
this
it's the
second or third of march at 7 00 pm
right here it'll be a quick service
about 30 minutes and it's just a great
time to
kick off the lint season remember why we
celebrate easter
and learn more about that season and to
be able to do it with our extended
family here at pleasant valley so again
wednesday march 2nd 7 pm
quick ash wednesday service would love
for you to join us so
how about if we just take a moment to
center ourselves
you're here you made it
95 of the job is just you know just
showing up that's
and you did that so good job you're here
you made it time to take a deep breath
so just take a deep breath take a deep
breath
and let's pray
god thank you for tonight
thank you for
this space
these people this community
this table
that is open to all
and god we give you this time
just pray that we would set
any to do's anything that
is coming up later or things that have
already happened just set those aside
god
and
help us to just be
to remember that we are loved
to remember that your grace is more than
enough
that god you are always with us
so we thank you for that
i pray your blessing over everyone here
everyone online
and we give you tonight in jesus name
amen
[Music]
thank you karen
if you guys want to stand with us
caitlyn's going to start us off on this
first song and we just invite you guys
into the space with us
there's no
real boundaries here between us and you
guys we're just a community singing
songs to god together so please join us
as you can
[Music]
you call me out upon the waters
the great unknown
where feet may fail
and there i find you in the mystery
in oceans deep
my faith will stand
and i will call upon your name
and keep my eyes above the ways
when oceans rise our soul will rest in
your embrace
and i am yours
[Music]
your grace abounds in deepest waters
your sovereign hands
[Music]
surrounds me
keep my eyes above the waves
when oceans arise my soul rests in your
embrace for i
are am
[Music]
lead me where my trust is without
borders let me walk upon the waters
wherever you would come me
take me deeper than my feet could ever
wander
my faith will be made stronger
in the presence of my savior
spirit lead
[Music]
take me deeper than my feet could ever
wander
my faith will be made stronger in the
presence of my savior
spirit lead me where my trust is without
borders let me walk upon the waters
wherever you would
[Music]
take me deeper than my feet could ever
wonder
and my faith will be made stronger
in the presence of my savior
[Music]
oh jesus
and keep my eyes above the waves
my soul will rest in your embrace
i am
yours
[Music]
philippians 4 6 and 7 says
don't worry about anything
instead pray about everything
tell god what you need
and thank him for what he's already done
then you will experience god's peace
which exceeds anything we can understand
his peace will guard your hearts and
your minds
as you live into christ jesus
and we're about to
do the prayer of the people and if
you're new here this is basically an
opportunity to take this scripture at
face value and instead of just worrying
about the things that are weighing on
our hearts we're lifting them up
together we're praying about everything
and trusting that god will meet us there
that he is carrying those burdens with
us and not only that but that we're
carrying them as a community together
so please
we invite you even if you're online to
share in the space we're going to read
this entire prayer out loud together and
there will be a space where you can lift
up the name or the situation that might
be burdening you tonight and then we'll
close out with the rest of the prayer
jesus
for the city of saxi texas
and for every city and community and all
of those who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick for the widow
and the orphan
for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and the destitute for
prisoners and captives and for all who
remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us and so we lift
these names and situations up to you
patty
steven denise
[Music]
on friday
and please pray for peace in ukraine
for the names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we have
kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have
life and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
i lose my ability
to be afraid
[Music]
and all the fear that held my
feet to the floor
it don't hold me anymore
when i
i see your face
everything changes in
the radiance of your smile
[Music]
you've got this way of
chasing away those
shadows that hang around
[Music]
lord i
fall down again
i'm finding out
just who
i
am
[Music]
i lose my ability
to be afraid
hear you say my name
[Music]
all the voices that once
fill my head
are gone when you speak
when i
see your face
everything changes in the
radiance of your smile
[Music]
you got this way of
chasing away those
shadows
[Music]
again
i'm finding now
just
i am
lord i fall
down
again i'm finding out just who
i am
[Music]
goodbye fear and goodbye shame
goodbye hopelessness and pain
i have heard the father
[Music]
is washed away
i've waited for this
[Music]
my moment
hello mercy hello
you have found me on my knees
i believe i'll never be the same
[Music]
and everything changes in the
radiance of your smile
you got this way of
chasing away those
shadows that hang around
when i
see your face
everything changes in the
radius of your smile
[Music]
you got this way of
chasing away those
shadows
[Music]
again
i'm finding out just who
i am
lord i fall
i'm finding out just who i am
[Music]
lord i
fall down again
[Music]
i'm finding out just who
i
am
hello joy and hello
[Music]
sing this chorus with us will you
take my
life
[Music]
take my
moments
[Music]
let them flow with
ceaseless praise
let them flow
in
ceaseless
[Music]
sing take my will
take my will
make it
it shall be
no
longer mine
take my heart
it shall be
your royal
throne
it
shall
[Music]
take my love my lord i pour
take my love my lord
treasure
store
take
myself and i
will be
[Music]
oh
it's god we lift up those words
we sing them
knowing god that there's so many times
where we
forget
to live a life that's consecrated to you
where we get caught up in the busyness
and the social media and the hype
and the things that our culture tells us
that we should be
before we remember to start our day
asking
where are you at god what are you doing
where do you want me
so god would you remind us
would you show us where your hands are
already at
work god would you give us feet that
would follow after you
would you give us ears
that are tuned into your voice give us a
heart that beats with yours god
would we would we be a community that's
marked by your love
by your counter cultural forgiveness
and grace
by your upside down kingdom
that sees people before tasks
that chooses forgiveness before hate
that looks for ways to right wrongs and
bring justice
god would we be your hands and feet
would our lives be ever only all for you
use us
be with us
thank you that we are yours
it's in your name we pray all these
things amen
thank you guys for worshiping with us if
you want to sit we are going to have
brett come up and start us out on our
message but while he does can y'all turn
to the people around you and say hello
make them feel welcome
well good evening everyone
grace and peace
welcome to the table it's uh it's great
to be with you all so so good and i also
want to extend a super warm welcome to
those join us online
you are not forgotten love you all lots
and
also anyone that is new here or just
kind of you know maybe it's not your
first time but you're making your way
kind of into the community um
we you know we really long one of our
values here at the table is to be
inclusive and um
there is something about you know a
community a little tribe it's easy to
get kind of tribal you know and kind of
like well we've got our friends you know
so we we have this value of being
inclusive because we want to keep
looking outside ourselves
and and just welcoming more in so um
yeah thank you for for being with us
tonight
so um we're in the midst of a series um
titled first peter part two and we're
basically just walking our way through
this book in the new testament
and
so we are on
to another doozy of a passage tonight
um if you were here last week you know
we were all up in another difficult
topic this was that was the topic of um
where peter gives instructions to slaves
um
and that was of course a text that's
been used in terrible ways in church
history and american history and all
that so we were that was kind of last
week so now on to this week the title of
the message is wives submission and
finding what you're looking for
some of you already know this passage
long before i read it but
let's go ahead and read it together so
first peter chapter 3 verses 1 through 7
says wives
in the same way submit yourselves to
your own husbands
so that if any of them do not believe
the word they may be won over without
words by the behavior of their wives you
can see here
in a similar way that last week was kind
of christian slaves to pagan
non-believing roman masters this is kind
of a similar setup you have christian
wives um relating to
um non-christian roman husbands that's
kind of the the waters he's navigating
um so verse two when they see the purity
and the reverence of your lives
your beauty should not come from outward
adornment such as elaborate hairstyles
the wearing of gold jewelry or fine
clothes rather it should be that of your
inner self the unfading beauty of a
gentle and quiet spirit which is of
great worth in god's sight for this is
the way the holy women of the past who
put their hope in god they used to adorn
themselves they submitted themselves to
their own husbands like sarah who obeyed
abraham and called him her lord
um there's some kind of conversation
among scholars about what exactly
they're quoting sarah at least in the
old testament doesn't ever actually say
that um so we don't know if it's like
some ancient translation or if it's uh
maybe even there is another story that
was kind of popular at this time about
abraham and sarah it's not in the bible
but it's like you know other books and
she does call him that so they wonder if
maybe it's like a reference to some
popular work at that time um we don't
know
we'll get to that in a moment though it
is
so let's keep going you are her
daughters if you do what is right and do
not give way to fear
uh verse seven husbands in the same way
be considerate as you live with your
wives and treat them with respect
as the weaker partner and as heirs with
you of the gracious gift of life so that
nothing will hinder your
prayers
so um
you know one of the challenges as i kind
of alluded to with the text last week
and even the one before that around it
was like the whole submission thing of
to the governing authorities you know
we've kind of had these three weeks of
just some really challenging passages
and um
i think at least this one you know i
think um
it's just i don't know i don't know how
it's striking you some specifically some
of the ladies here it might be um
depending on your church background it
could be quite triggering honestly like
just kind of like uh you know where is
where is this going and um because there
is there's a whole history you know
about how this text has been used um and
specifically that line you know wives
submit yourselves to your own husbands
um
a very kind of famous or some might call
it kind of infamous passage um in fact
i've heard you know to
for those unfamiliar with like well i
don't know maybe there's a few of you
that this didn't strike you as overly
weird perhaps um you know just to make
it clear this this text has been used
like for example i've heard of of
pastors um not ones i've known
personally but i've heard of pastors
using a passage like this to encourage
or kind of instruct or kind of guide
home a like a wife who's like
experiencing for example like physical
abuse
um in her marriage and then is
instructed to like well you know
you need to return home because
um you know he's your spiritual
authority you need to submit to your
spiritual authority as you know he's the
husband and you know um so you can see
where this site gets real sideways real
quick right um y'all tracking i see some
i see a lot of heads going like this so
i'll take that as a yes um
so but heck even if though maybe this is
like you're you're new to christian
faith and you've never even heard of
first peter chapter three and you're
just hearing it for the first time and
my hunch is even if that's true and you
have no idea about the whole history or
anything um it's still it probably
strikes you as i'm guessing you know a
little bit kind of cringey or just kind
of like i don't know like there's all
the language of submission which can
just be a question of like what do you
where is that going what does that mean
exactly
um and then there's all the stuff around
you know adornment and like don't i
don't know basically don't wear makeup
you know
um which can be just a little bit kind
of culturally strange and uh and then of
course there's the
the part towards the end about the
example of sarah who called her husband
lord um i have no idea what i would do
if my wife maggie um was just like i
just want to be biblical and so i'm
going to start calling you lord uh
i just i don't i don't think that's a
good idea don't do that uh that's very
strange actually there's a um
a book
uh there's uh there's a well christian
writer i should say rachel held evans
god rest her soul she passed away a few
years ago
far too young but she was a wonderful
wonderful writer so she wrote this book
a year of biblical womanhood how a
liberated woman found herself sitting on
the roof covering her head and calling
her husband master
and that subtitle that very end there is
an allusion to first peter chapter three
verse six
because other translations use the term
master some lord others
both sound very problematic to me um
and so this is uh i mean it's a
fantastic book like
really funny um like there's a part
where uh there's a passage well
basically just to give you the idea of
the book she took a year
to like try to live everything
um
that the bible says a woman should do
like
she did it so some of it was kind of
ongoing like she sustained the practice
of the year other things she just did
like one time but that was her goal was
to try to do everything the bible says
women should do so like for example
there's a passage that talks about how a
woman um should praise her husband at
the city gates
and so she made this like you know how
you'll get a football game and you'll
like have a sign like cheering on your
team you know and so she made one for
her husband and like went to this i
think it was sort of the front of the
neighborhood i can't remember the exact
place but kind of went oh i think his
name was dan so like go dan is awesome
he's the best she just cheered him on
it's fantastic now just to be clear
you know um evan's like she was a
christian and and um deeply committed to
her face so her point wasn't just like
to mock the bible or mock christianity
or something that wasn't her point um
instead it was to show um i don't know
what would be the words kind of the um
kind of the the struggle and the
challenges and a little bit of the
silliness that can happen
if you
just try to follow the literal text all
the time without ever translating for
culture
right and without ever if you just don't
do that um you can get to a really silly
place as she evidenced by um i mean for
example sitting on the roof this was
another thing that's in the bible it's
you know so this is the great album or
an album but a
photo for the book isn't it with her
sitting that's her that's rachel sitting
on the roof with her head covered you
know so you can see how this it's a
little bit it's a little bit silly and
um and this is kind of what happens
right um if we just approach it with a
sort of wooden um literalism
and and really it's about the way we
it's easy to kind of approach the bible
as this very flat text making timeless
announcements no interpretation needed
you know um
and that's just not what it is you know
we all have to interpret we have to
translate we have to say okay that was
then this is now what do we do how do we
live this um
what here is beautiful good and true and
resonates with christ um what perhaps
not so much you know and that's
something the church always is doing and
you know it has to um has to continue
doing so um because the way i think of
the the scriptures are kind of this
um they are testimony to the capital w
word jesus if you have been around the
table for a while you know that's kind
of our doctrine of scripture jesus is
the word of god scripture is testimony
to the word a metaphor we've um used is
the idea of the finger pointing to the
moon you know if someone's like look at
that
and you're like what and you're just
staring at their finger like what and
they're like no look
look at it and you just keep looking at
their hand that would be very silly
thing right the point is to look at what
it's pointing to and that's that's
scripture scripture is the finger
pointing to the moon the moon is jesus
christ right in the metaphor like
that's the point
um
and so we need to you know we need to
keep this um this in mind so there's
actually i want to read you a wonderful
passage this is a quote from a year of
biblical womanhood um by evans and um
it's a it's really a she's reflecting on
scripture as a whole and i think in a
really insightful way um and you'll hear
a number of references to first peter 3
um throughout throughout this quote so
she says uh this if you're looking for
verses
with which to support slavery
you will find them
if you're looking for verses
with which to abolish slavery
you will find them
if you're looking for verses with which
to oppress women you will find them if
you're looking for verses with which to
liberate or honor women you will find
them if you're looking for reasons to
wage war you will find them if you're
looking for reasons to promote peace
you will find them
if you're looking for an outdated
irrelevant ancient text
you will find it
if you're looking for truth
believe me
you will find it this is why there are
times when the most instructive question
to bring to the text is not
what does it say
[Music]
but what am i looking
for i suspect jesus knew this when he
said ask and it will be given to you
seek and you will find
knock and the door will be opened
if you want to do violence in this world
you will always find the weapons
if you want to heal
you will always find the bomb
amen huh
i mean we could just end i guess
that's you're like that we wouldn't be
sad man honestly it wouldn't be sad
it's uh it's powerful
so i love that um the question
um
you know what is not just what does it
say what does the bible say what does it
say what does it say
the deeper question is what am i looking
for right because this gets that
interpretation we often find what we're
looking for
and that's inescapable just to be human
is to find what you're looking for in
even the bible
i think that's incredibly why so this
was kind of the guiding question i
brought to this message tonight into
this topic what what i want to go um
looking for is a liberating life-giving
reading of this text because if we want
to find a sort of sexist misogynistic
interpretation this passage no problem
it's right there on the surface
you know that's easy enough
um
but let's try harder
let's go let's go looking for a
liberating life-giving reading of this
passage
and um that's what we're going to do so
to do that we do we need to go back just
like we've done in message after message
in the series we need to go back i'm
going to do this part quick because i
know we've done a lot of roman history
y'all like no no more roman history
please
sorry
give me two minutes
um
so let's talk about the households the
household so basically in roman culture
the household was a a microcosm it was a
picture of the roman empire as a whole
meaning at the top of the roman
hierarchy of like the government and
like the whole system you have who
caesar right the emperor
and so in the household
you see where this is going at the top
it's a very hierarchical structure
and at the top of the household
who do you have you have not literally
caesar but you have a mini emperor
and you uh
you see how this got out of hand
you know and what's that about absolute
power and stuff you know
corrupts absolutely and all that yeah um
so basically that's how the roman house
would function it was the mini emperor
the it was it was a man the male
um the freeborn roman citizen male was
the not just like in our context we'd
kind of be well maybe you know the man
should be like the leader of the home or
something it's maybe how christians
would word it um and in like roman
culture it was like that ramped up times
10 like not just the leader in some
vague sense no like the emperor
of the household so that was the
situation he had the
little mini emperor the male um the
patter familias the father of the
household um then you had
under that um the household that was
also like when i say household we tend
to think oh like the nuclear family and
after work they'd go there and hang out
from you know like 5 30 p.m to 8 30 pm
in the evenings and before they went to
bed
not exactly so um
they would work it was a place of
business as well so every family had the
family business and whole wings of the
house were devoted to the family
business
and so you had again the the little mini
emperor he was sort of the president the
ceo of the business
and then
everyone else was the workers you had
any wives any um children slaves they
were kind of the workers in the family
business
and then finally um the household was
also a temple again in our context it's
like well no the household's like the
house where you chill and watch tv and
then you like go to church
and not they did have temples outside
but the household was a place of worship
so you had little little areas devoted
to the worship of various gods now why
well because you wanted the household to
thrive and specifically wanted the
family business
to do real good so you kind of chose his
household which gods were going to
worship and we and and something that
was really key were that all of the
subordinate members in the household
um get on the same page by the way i'm
not just making all this up i'm i forgot
to mention there's a new testament
theologian i think her name was caroline
something hodge caroline johnson hodge
maybe i think we have a picture of her
but um that's who i'm drawing some of
this um this from there she is caroline
johnson hodge um
so
can you see how
with this kind of background information
we're kind of heading for conflict
in the christian community
if you have christian wives
and
non-christian
roman husbands
um
here's here's why this is actually a
quote from plutarch a roman citizen kind
of writing around this time
he says a married woman should therefore
worship and recognize the gods whom her
husband holds dear and these alone
the door must be closed to strange cults
and foreign superstitions no god takes
pleasure and cult performed furtively
and in secret by
a woman
see this is peter's context he's not
writing abstract theology about why men
are awesome and women are not so much
like that's not his it's not what he's
trying to do he's writing in in this
kind of context
he's writing to christian wives
who are now
um
worshiping jesus and they're bringing
that worship into their household and
their roman husbands are probably not
thrilled about this change why um
well kind of i'll name two quick reasons
a because these christian wives were
deviating from the worship of the
household gods
right which remember that the family
business is going to thrive
what do we need we need everyone on the
same page
right but all of a sudden these
christian wives and probably peter's
encouraging them like worship jesus and
not these other god not zeus you know
like no zeus and that's probably causing
conflict um in the household um in fact
we know like it's again it's very
different from today where like uh you
know a husband can be like well i'm a
christian and the wife to be like well
i'm not or vice versa and you know like
okay well i'm going to church okay you
have fun you know
that 2000 years ago it's not he's not
the roman the little mini emperor is not
saying well you go you do you you know
no
it's not that's not how it's working so
a they're deviating from the worst of
the household gods is like very
questionable um and then second
they are joining this strange christian
cult with its destruction of the social
order
uh what do i mean by destruction of the
social order here's another quote this
is from a writer a roman writer named
celsius who aims the following criticism
at christianity he says this uh
christians injunctions in other words
their commands or teachings are like
this and now he's gonna kind of quote
christians it's not like a direct quote
but you can tell he's he's kind of
poking at and drawing from actual
christian thought at this time they say
stuff like this let no one educated
no one wise no one sensible draw near
for these abilities are thought by us to
be evils
but as for anyone ignorant
anyone stupid anyone uneducated anyone
who is a child remember jesus teaching
that
if you're going to enter the kingdom
come like a child
you know
if anyone's a child oh
let him come boldly
by the now how he ends the quote now
it's just him kind of reflecting on that
he says by the fact that they themselves
admit
that these people
are worthy
of their god they show that they want
and are able to convince only the
foolish
the dishonorable
and the stupid
and only slaves and women
and little children
and it's pretty
it's terrible right
but
can you see what he's getting at like
this is the line that that really stands
out to me they admit that these people
are worthy of their god
who are who are these people well it's
people named
right you see in roman culture as we've
kind of alluded to in weeks past um
women
slaves
children
kind of foreigners even like we're just
not really people
not like fully people
and and yet what was happening these
christian churches were welcoming them
in
and so christianity started getting this
reputation
right because from a roman perspective
those people not only are they not
people but they're well they're all the
adjectives
just described right ignorant
foolish stupid
dishonorable
um you know as i came to this this quote
i realized like this is what's
completely sort of mind-blowing
kind of mind-bending in a way
is the fact that the very so basically
the last two weeks we've been in some
awkward passages haven't we just cringey
just like oh kind of not just not our
favorites you know these aren't the ones
that people post on facebook like
inspirational scriptures you know just
it's not making that list
um in fact quite the opposite like in
ways i'd say probably the ones in the
last two weeks in particular are
probably top five most uncomfortable oh
let's not talk about those passages in
the entire new testament
now here's what's completely
mind-bending
is that
it like in our minds oh i actually i
wrote down a quote you can go ahead and
put up on the screen like basically we
read peter as this terribly kind of
backwards
hyper conservative religious person
when
he and his churches were being condemned
by the surrounding roman culture for
being overly progressive and radical
can you see how that's like there's some
irony here like the very passages were
just like oh gosh oh don't talk about
those those are embarrassing oh that's
oh i don't even i can't don't say it
don't read it out loud just let us read
it on the screen but don't say it
and yet the whole reason peter's having
to write these words having to wrestle
with these topics in the first place
address these groups of people is
precisely because
those groups of people
women for example were being not only
welcomed into the church
included which wouldn't have happened in
roman religion it's like the men
are religious you know
but the women were being included and
even welcomed into leadership which we
have evidence in the new testament and
there's this idea of the new testament
it's like just super oppressive of women
and it's like well there's texts that
are kind of along those lines we just
looked at one
and and yet there's others that like
allude to they were being really
empowered like welcomed into leadership
i mean there's all there's all sorts of
reasons like for example there's a
sociologist named rodney stark who
estimates two-thirds of the early church
was women
because they what they were flocking to
the church
like joining it in droves
why well it's the reason i mean this is
why celsius that roman terrible writer
we just quoted um
that's like that's what that's why he
sees it it's like a woman's religion
you know it's that's a slave religion
like that's they they accept anyone they
welcome anyone can you see in other
words what was happening was the
christian church was welcoming them in
and then empowering them involving them
uplifting them
in ways that was it was making waves in
the culture it was sending shockwaves
through the culture and there was even a
pushback
and it so it's just isn't there
something ironic in the very text that
we're just like oh this is terrible like
in its day and time
was seen as the church was seen as
completely the opposite
isn't that crazy like
i think this this shifts i think it
should shift our perspective
um
and and get us thinking because
basically i think what happens is we
just of course we do like we read the
text with 21st century eyes right we do
and and just to be clear i'm not here to
try and defend everything peter's saying
which is why this message is not a
line-by-line exegesis of that passage
where i try to like convince you
everything is awesome i'm like i'm not
i'm not doing that
um
and instead i well and even you know as
a further example i wanted to look just
at verse seven that's kind of
interesting he closes with this little
this little um push at the husbands now
he's talking to the christian husbands
who are actually hearing this letter as
it's read in the church did you catch
what he said husbands in the same way be
considerate as you live with your wives
treat them with respect as the weaker
partner now again that language weaker
we kind of
what's he mean well i think probably
means like maybe perhaps biologically
like physically it could also be just
culturally more vulnerable um in in that
time women would have been more
vulnerable
but then it continues and then see them
as heirs with you
right in other words as kind of equals
receivers of the gracious gift of life
so that nothing will hinder your prayers
i really like that closing line it's
like it's like his little jab
he's a little like in other words
men
he's saying
you start acting more like romans and
less like christians
god just might ignore your petitions
i mean that's what he's that's what he
just said like god just made like you
literally you could pray and god's like
nope
don't care
like what
you know can you see that for all of the
awkwardness for all of the kind of
like peter at least in that moment he's
like way down the road of celsius
right like he's
better
um
and that's that's kind of what i want to
get at tonight like church in the end i
don't think we need to literally like
replicate with some sort of strange
wooden literalism exactly peter's
commands and then be like yes perfect
let's just do that in the 21st century
like no
no instead what i want you to see like
i want to just name there was there was
something though
in the first century
that was shifting
that was changing
in the churches
and that shift that change we might call
it kind of a trajectory
right
the trajectory was
good
it was a better trajectory and so i
think our call
is is again not to just replicate what
they did
but to to catch the trajectory to kind
of get the spirit of the text
and to see the changes they were making
and then say okay let's continue going
that direction
riding the wave um
in our own day and age
in other words um
like here at the table
let's continue like let's uplift women
let's empower women not just like oh
you're welcome you're included but like
empower
them
um like ladies we need you like bringing
your full selves here
we're not gonna throw like we can't
thrive if like half the community is
sort of disengaged or kind of like we
had held it in arm's length in some
weird way like no no no like let's be a
community where
our women like you you ladies are like
empowered and loved and seen and valued
and
um
can thrive same for our little girls
you know like i want them to grow up in
a community where they don't get i don't
know even in sort of unspoken ways a
certain um
kind of second class citizen thing being
communicated
you know like no no no let's
let's do away with it let's see the
trajectory and let's keep going let's be
a church community where women know that
they are full
um full partakers full reflectors of the
divine image
every bit as any man ever was
i think that's the spirit of christ
that's where the early church was trying
to start making those shifts
they're trying and so let's like see
what they're trying to do and let's like
take it further that sound good
cool all right let me pray for you
lord jesus
i lift up
every woman here um
you know i don't know everyone's history
but god they may have felt um at some
point belittled or put down
by the scriptures or by their church
they were raised in so for every
um every woman who might have wondered
like if maybe she doesn't really measure
up in some way in the name of jesus may
those lies and chains be broken
may women step forward into leadership
and they step into the full equality
and into a deep and profound knowledge
that they are
deeply valued and seen
and may our whole church community
be the better for it
that's our prayer god in the name of the
father the son and the holy spirit
amen
all right you guys
as he was talking i was like
glad i don't like jewelry
if we if we had to follow that law it
would take me forever just to get into
the building because i would be like one
two three
what's better than one great bracelet
seven great bracelets
okay so we're gonna have fun with this
last song i hope i hope you guys will
have fun with us tomorrow's valentine's
day and y'all i just want to be cheesy
for a moment okay we spend half of our
sundays listening to roman history we
just need a little cheesiness okay
we have to balance out the bread vibes
in the room
so listen
this is a classic song most of you are
gonna know it from the first few notes
please sing along with us i asked gary
to do a straight up serenade to karen
and he said he would weep the whole way
through
so that's sweet right i had to say that
what he would really appreciate more is
if like mike and marilyn came to the
front and started a dance party and we
would all join in like you know this
could be like group dance no
i mean you're welcome too we won't stop
you but maybe instead grab a lighter you
know
do
kumbaya together if you're here with
someone special squeeze their hand
if you're not think of someone else in
the room that has brought love and
laughter to your life all right this is
just let's have fun with it in honor of
valentine's day tomorrow
here it comes
love guys
[Music]
have i told you there's no one else
above you
[Music]
you fill my heart with gladness
take away all my sadness
ease my troubles that's what you do
[Music]
for the
morning sun in all its glory
greets the day
with hope and comfort too
you fill my life with laughter
and somehow you make it better
ease my troubles that's what you do
there's a love that's divine
and it shows in its mind
like the sun
[Music]
at the end of the day
we should give thanks and pray
[Music]
to the one
have i told you lately that i love you
y'all sing it with me
have i told you
there's no one else above you
[Music]
you fill my heart with gladness
you take away all my sadness
you ease my troubles that's what you do
[Music]
there's a love that's divine
and it's yours and it's mine
like the
[Music]
the sun
we should give thanks and pray
to the ones
[Music]
that i love you
have i told you
there's no one else above you
you filled my life with laughter
[Music]
somehow you make it better
you ease my troubles that's what you do
[Music]
you take away all my sadness
you fill my life with gladness
ease my troubles that's what you do
[Applause]
[Music]
anybody in the room i'm just saying but
thanks you guys
um
yeah thanks for being with us tonight um
thank you for being here especially on
this sunday where it required getting
here a little earlier and maybe shifting
some plans that communicates love that's
great
and i do hope you feel loved i know when
we talk about passages like that my
brain starts to think about
the inclusivity of them and especially
here at the table like how do we how do
we wrestle with this stuff especially
when we're talking about husbands and
wives when we have wives and wives and
husbands and husbands and we're talking
about genders and when there's
non-binary and gender fluid people so it
really makes me think about that and i
appreciate the fact that that's not
off the table like that's very much part
of this conversation so may we continue
to
be inclusive as much as we can in our
thoughts and as we're
as we're looking at scripture and as
we're communicating love with each other
i think it's important i really do
so with that said if you guys could
stand up
i would like to
leave you with these words as you go
into your week ahead
um
and
if you would like
oh and by the way a benediction which is
what i'm gonna share right now is just a
fancy word for blessing
just a fancy word for
i hope you feel loved this week i hope
you remember that you matter this week
and that god is with you this week
that's what this this time right here is
for as we close and go out into our week
so if you would like to receive this
blessing just go and hold your hands
out
you are a child of god
you are a child
of god
this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are
and go
filled with god's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these same
gifts
of unconditional love
and grace
to everyone you come in contact with
be blessed have a great week we hope to
see you back here next sunday
good night
i'm no longer
i am a child of god